[Applause]
when I was 14 my parents intended to
marry me off to a man of their choosing
I refused that choice to define my
family shaped everything in my life and
set me on the path to become Who I am
today but was very painful at times and
continues to be so
my parents were raised and traditional
uneducated Moroccan families where a
girl's main value is measured by her
virginity they emigrated to Belgium and
I was born raised and educated there I
did not accept their view of the world
when I said no to them I paid for daily
in terms of physical and emotional abuse
but eventually I escaped from their home
and became a federal police effective
who could help protect the rights of
others my specialty was investigating
cases in counterterrorism child
abduction and homicide our loft at work
it was extremely fulfilling with my
Muslim background Arabic language skills
and an interest in working
internationally I decided to seek new
challenges after decades of being a
police officer I was recruited to become
an investigator of sexual and
gender-based violence as a member of the
Justice rapid response in you and woman
Raza Justice Robert response is an
organization for criminal investigations
of mass atrocities they run on both
public and private funding and provides
evidence and reports to more than 100
participating countries many countries
in conflict are often unable to provide
a just process to those who have been
victim of mass violence to respond to
that Justice Roberts response was
created in partnership with you and
woman together just as rapid response
any woman recruited trained and sir
to fight more than 250 professions with
a specific expertise in sexual and
gender-based violence like me our
investigations are carried out under
international law and our fundings
eventually become evidence to prosecute
war criminals this mechanism provides
hope to victims that justice and
accountability may someday be found in
the wake of war and conflict let me tell
you about the most challenging work I've
ever done this was in Iraq since the
rise of the Islamic State of Iraq and
Syria or Isis
this group has systematically attacked
and tortured many religious minorities
and ethnicities such as the Christians
the shia turkmen Shia Muslims Shia
Shabaks and their cities the persecution
of the Yazidis has been especially
horrific on the third and 15 of August
2014 Isis attacked approximately 20
villages and towns in Sinjar Iraq they
executed all the males including over
the age of 14 including the elderly and
disabled they divided up the woman and
girls raped them and sold them into
sexual and domestic slavery one month
later a UN Human Rights Council
resolution led to the fact-finding
mission on Iraq to investigate and
document alleged violations and abuses
committed by Isis and associated groups
I was sent to investigate the atrocities
committed against the Yazidis with the
focus on sexual and gender-based crimes
the adidas are a Kurdish speaking Aetna
religious community based in the
northern Iraq their belief system
incorporates aspect of Judaism
Christianity Islam and Zoroastrianism
for hundreds of years
Muslims and Christians who do not
understand their beliefs have condemned
the cities as devil worshippers Isis
thought of them in this way and vowed to
destroy them ok let's do an experimental
thought here I want you to think about
your worst
sexual experience and we call it in
detail now turn to the person to your
right and describe that experience I
know it's difficult but of course I've
been expected to do that you would all
be uncomfortable and embarrassed but so
imagine an 11-year old girl in the
Middle East who was not educated about
sexuality who was taken from her comfort
zone her family who witnessed the
execution of her father and brothers
having to describe in detail the rape
that she faced in a culture we're
talking about sexuality is taboo her
only way of recovering her honor is to
hide a crime believe she was married
against her will or deny the events are
a shame and fear of being rejected
I interviewed a girl who I will call Ida
she was purchased by an Isis leader or
Amir together with 13 other girls aged
between 11 and 18 years old amongst a
group for her three nieces and two
cousins the 14 girls were taken to a
house full of Isis fighters in Imam was
present who made it clear that their
religion was wrong and the only good
paths was to accept Islam and marry a
Muslim man the Emir wrote the names of
the girls on 14 small pieces of paper to
Isis fighters would pick a piece of
paper each they would call out the name
written on the paper and those girls
were forcibly taken into another room
when the Emir and a mom heard the two
girls screaming as they were being raped
they began laughing both were telling
the other girls that have two girls
should enjoy the experience instead of
screaming after a while the girls were
brought back into the room they were in
shock and were bleeding they confirmed
that they had been married and suffered
a lot of pain it is important to
consider the fact they they had been
raised to believe in sexual intercourse
would one man in their lifetime their
husband
the only connection that they could make
in the shocked state is to define their
rape as marriage before the next two
girls were taken to be rape Ida made a
terrifying decision as the oldest of the
group she convinced the AMIA to let him
use the bathroom in order to wash
themselves before marriage Ida had been
told by one of the girls that she notice
rat poison in the bathroom the 14 girls
decided to end their suffering by
drinking the poison before the poison
took full effects they were discovered
by Isis and taken to the hospital where
they survived Isis decided to separate
the girls and sell them individually Ida
was think to another house and brutally
raped after she attempted again to kill
herself with her headscarf she was
beaten and raped every two days after
four months in captivity I'd have found
the courage to escape she never saw the
other 13 girls again
I interviewed item multiple times she
was willing to speak to me because she
had heard from other victims that word
that there was a woman from the UN who
understood her complicated culture I
looked into her eyes and listen deeply
to the stories of her darkest hours
we established a personal connection
that continues to this day my upbringing
made it easy for me to understand her
extreme sense of shame and her fear of
being rejected these types of
investigations are not only about
gathering information and evidence but
they're also about victim support the
bonds I established with the victims
strengthens their confidence Elron Ellis
to seek justice as she considered her
escape writer like all year ZD survivors
faced a dilemma should she continue to
suffer the views of her captors or would
it be better to return home where she
would face shame rejection and possibly
only killing I know all too well the
pain of being rejected by my Moroccan
community in Belgium and I did not want
this to happen that easily
so group of Concerned entities including
the UN NGOs politicians and members of
the Yazidi community approached a
religious leader Baba Chef after many
meetings he realized that these girls
had not disrespected their religion by
being forcibly converted to Islam and
married Isis fighters instead they have
been abducted raped and sexually as
waved I'm happy to report and after
meetings baba Sheikh announced publicly
that the survivors should be treated as
victims and embraced by the community
this message was heard throughout the
community and eventually reads to
survive is being held captive by Isis
after his declaration of support the
survivors were motivated to escape from
Isis as Ida had done and many young
Yazidi woman took the ball set ever
turned home to their communities baba
shakes public pronouncement saved the
lives of many young Yazidi women both in
captivity and after they escaped sadly
not all religious leaders agreed to talk
with us some victims had far worse
outcomes and the Yazidis for example
only forty three of the five to six
hundred victims from the shia turkmen
community were able to return home after
escaping Isis some of them were advised
by their family to stay with Isis or
commit suicide in order to save the
honour of the family
Germany established a project to support
survivors of Isis by providing
psychosocial support and housing for
1,100 woman and children including Ida I
visit either several times during my
work I am so proud of her
and the other victims the progress they
have made is remarkable it is really
moving to see how many of them despite
their struggles have benefited from this
program the program includes individual
and group counseling art therapy music
therapy sport activities language
courses school and order integration
events what I observed was that removing
the victims from an area of conflict to
a country at peace had a positive impact
on all of the
this project caught the attention of
other countries and they were interested
to help more CD's the acedia woman and
gold still call or text me to tell me
about her grades at school from trips
they've taken or don't fool me about
their future dreams like writing a book
about what they have faced with Isis
sometimes they are said and feel the
need to talk again about the events I'm
not a psychologist and I have faith
secondary PTSD from the horrific stories
but I keep encouraging them to talk and
I keep listening because I do not want
them to feel alone in their suffering
through these anecdotes I see a bigger
picture emerging these women are girls
are healing they are no longer afraid to
seek justice without hope there can be
no justice and without justice there can
be no hope every third and 15 of August
it's my remembers day and I reach out to
the aucd's to let them know them
thinking about them
they're always happy when I do dance
it's an emotional day for them this past
August I spoke with Ida she was so happy
to announce that one of her nieces who
was abducted with her was finally
released out of Isis hands in Syria and
returned to Iraq can you believe that
after four years today her biggest wish
is for whole family now located across
three continents to be reunited and I
hope they will when I think about the
survivors I work with I remember the
words of an Egyptian doctor writer and
one my rights activists now while and
said OE
in her book woman at phone zero she
wrote life is very hard and the only
people who really live are those who are
harder than life itself these victims
have been through on a magical pain but
with a little help
they show how resilient they are each
has her own perspective on what kind of
justice she seeks and I believe deeply
that a credible justice process is key
to her she reclaims her dignity and fans
closure with her throng
justice is not only about punishing the
perpetrator
it's about victims feeling that crimes
committed against them have been
recorded and recognized by the rule of
law for me it has been the experience of
a lifetime to work with these survivors
because I share their sorrow their
language and their culture we connect on
a deepest human level this itself is an
act of healing to be heard to be seen to
be given compassion instead of
condemnation one we got so close to
people on pain
it creates pain for the investigators to
my work is challenging heartbreaking and
trauma and you sing but let me tell you
why I do it when I meet the survivors of
these mass atrocities want to hold their
hands and look in their eyes it does not
erase my own pain but it does make it
almost worthwhile and there's nothing I
would rather be doing when I see these
brave survivors struggling to connect
again to their own self-worth to their
families to their place in a society
that values them it is an honor to bear
witness it is a privilege to seek
justice and that is healing too for all
of us thank you
[Applause]